good afternoon everybody welcome to this
meeting I've started it now that clock
says three o'clock but I suspect that so
it is really just two o'clock is this
the clock depart you're taking
responsibility for the clocks Department
I am mr. perks Ryan okay we start with
apologies for absence apology to receive
from counsel Pemberton and also cancer
Atkinson thank you
right so what hasn't counselor a Kinston
center vice-chairman is that what it was
there okay we might wish to reflect
apparently I've had a note from Council
of tablets in this morning his mother
who have been living in Ireland died on
Friday so he's had to decamp to the
Irish Republic somewhat suddenly over
the weekend but that explains why he is
not with us today disclosures of
interests none thank you minutes we
implant two meetings there you've got
the white paper minutes of the ninth and
the 16th I'm going to ask you to approve
both of those there is an exempt minute
from the 9th which I must confess I bust
everybody an apology and that was sent
to me for clearance but I fail to do so
so I'll pick that one up at the next
meeting
so nobody would have seen that so but
the white paper minutes are circulated
with the agendas is it your wish that I
sign these is a true record of those two
meetings agreed thank you
right moving on
item four air-quality annual status
report this is a motion that came up and
we are asked or invited to make an
appropriate recommendations is the job
of the cabinet to make up
recommendations back to Council on this
motion and indeed councillor Brian have
you got a particular preference for how
we handle this and just like to
recommend it goes further in scrutiny
committee for consideration and report
back to the Covenant no that's fine
Castle Richards what I don't know if you
change that or not but I would suggest
to go to the rogatory given this is this
is under their remit so I suggest we
send it's a regulatory for their review
it's another recommendation added to the
agenda yeah I was going to say can we
send it to the regulatory committee mr.
Grafton it's not in the list of options
I'm sorry to bounce this one on you yeah
that's that's okay so that these these
are the options are set out in the
Constitution as agreed by council I can
see that there is a connection with
regulatory committee I I imagine that
the reason why the standard paragraph is
there is in case the overview and
scrutiny committee want to work with the
cabinet in order to produce the
information that the cabinet will need
to make a decision we haven't checked
that but it is an option councillor
Morse
assume it's this cabinets decision at
the end of the day as to whether the
persevere with the air quality
management area and so therefore
whichever way we go it should be a
report back to this cabinet on the skin
yeah I would have thought over the in
scooting might be better placed because
that's a normal role but on the cabinet
can I just say one further point chillin
because I can well understand why the
government wants us to cancel the air
quality management area the government
is judged nationally on how it's doing
on air quality the more air quality
management areas there are the worse it
can be said that the government is doing
so I can well understand pressure from
government to cancel the air quality
management area but I do believe that's
in the best interests of the residence
Council house never being one to
volunteer if you wanted it sent it to
overview and scrutiny I would just
remind members here that we've got a
fairly program would it make it right
the the issue is quite clearly in my
mind is kindness to go often said these
are options laid out in the Constitution
as fart of our procedure for dealing
with motions members motions at council
council the riches raises a valid point
that the monetary of air quality is the
responsibility of the regulatory
committee and whereas normally I would
not expect the regulatory committee to
make recommendations to cabinet is
Liberty all committees or liberty
effectively to advise cabinet that's
slightly different to making
recommendations as I shall come to later
but the issue is that we are in a
position where I think the cabinet would
appreciate some technical expertise
before it makes a decision
now I'm in your hands it if you want us
to to seek the of the use of the
regulatory committee I'm fairly certain
that they will be happy to provide them
mr. Grafton just thinking about it a
little bit further and hearing what
people have said one solution would be
to stagger the feedback that you get so
perhaps it goes to regulatory first then
he goes to the OSC and then back to the
cabinet yeah the OSC does have
constitutional powers to make
recommendations to cabinet the other
committees do not so that might well be
a solution yes council Richards so that
I'm clear is that suggestion that we did
we send this to overview and scrutiny
who then send it to the regulatory who
then sent it back to overview and
scrutiny sending them back to us
I'll stray away from the actual steps
but but I don't see any problem in
getting a few from the regulatory
committee even notwithstanding that the
rules that we have right so let us
therefore seek a recommendation from the
OSC an intern ask them to get a view of
the regulatory committee would you be
comfortable with that recommendation
counselor house oh yes okay so is that
our course of action is that agreed
thank you right next item is the motion
rail shuttle service from Long Marston
- honey born
and this is got councillor Richards name
against it so again I'll ask him to put
some input into this process albeit
briefly I think I would like to hear
from cancer bands who has won the put
emotion before me I got a little fun
council of ours this morning I was
supposed to be on the radio to support
this motion and BBC couldn't find
anybody about it that somebody came on
and said the airfield was a wonderful
place but it was there intercept you the
situation is that there is a line as you
been on four miles long to honey born
station at honey born station there is a
platform and a gate through to the
London train there are fifteen to
sixteen trains
either way to London whereas we've only
got two from Stratford situation is that
we now have a company in a right next
door in our area he's producing these
shuttles the first battery taught Warren
came off the production line beginning
of this month October and a number of
being sold to various operators we went
on a prototype before within the hot
weather with that and he can
air-conditioning or was there
conditioning means somebody has it was
it yes and we would like to extend the
line to the airfield on the airfield
plan there is a place for a station and
as far as I know 40% of the people that
actually use the Train now go by cycle I
don't want my or both which is a bit
surprising but I have looked into it so
on the Greenway would be an ideal play
to have it first never 6,000 houses or
however many are going there where which
I even have agreed that their line could
be used with most of it is in which over
and they're estimating somewhere between
eleven and twelve thousand houses in our
area or their area between there and Ani
born under the core strategy there is a
look mister I should say a prominent
businessman has got an industrial park
where the line is or was and under the
core strategy and I worked there that
they there have been agreed the
inspector that they can be a loop on
Station Road on Boston for just this
particular deal as far as I'm concerned
I wasn't expecting as much support when
I thought of the idea and it isn't sort
of just come to my mom because it's a a
number of people need or weren't able to
go on the train which ran for two days
for the show and a member of the LA
Martin parish council and one from
clipper chambers was supposed to be able
to one problem Martin has come in full
support earnest I think it's obviously
the way forward I could go on at length
in the type of books and all the other
things he hadn't acted to speak I don't
think but the far as I'm concerned
I would like to move it forward because
the inter structure for the airfield in
my eyes and many years is not sufficient
and been able to get to London easily
where forty percent of the people in me
and bail actually go now about four days
a week nineteen to work and when if you
want to do
I I'm very fortunate I haven't got the
dog I haven't got the dog with me today
but somebody else is coming so as far as
I'm concerned I would like it to move
forward and I've done a lot of work
ministry doubts about it's agreed that
they can imagine is tabled it must
therefore move forward it's a question
of how we know it is a freight line it's
issued by Allen visibly for all their
heavy freight coming from Europe the
British Rail say that it's the bit
that's there is suitable per passenger
traffic if required and we have to move
forward
British Rail well where do you get
pretty trial from I'll tell you for a
slightly more concise and I do
appreciate your extensive intro thank
you and so I suggest that and we haven't
got any evidence of the moment of
support or deny this I suggest that we
move forward with a report from officers
at the very least perhaps a feasibility
study to be provided so I suggest we we
moved to recommendation B which is to
defer and await await those reports and
bring back to cabinet a future date I'll
be happy with that we've just agreed to
take it forward Peter with a report from
offices it will it will live on
right we're gonna get on with the
meeting now Peter so can you sit down
please
okay next item item six site allocations
plan built-up area boundaries for local
service villages these have been
reported to cabinet at a previous
meeting through the minutes of the
leaders policy advisory group who have
looked at these we sent the whole lot
out to consultation right by the
parishes concerns that's each of the
built-up area boundaries and have agreed
with the parishes and with elpac and
with me as portfolio holder where the
built-up area boundary should lie now
that normally presumes that effectively
it would be an exception to build
outside the built-up area boundary
although I did note when I went there on
another application that one was
approved at pillars and priors outside
the built-up area boundary but a recent
planning committee east but we had to
actually approve this then we're about
to do so today if you all agree with the
boundaries that have been drawn on the
sheath of maps that come with it as you
will see in the majority of cases the
built-up area is a continuous area but
one or two places like one of my
colleagues picked out earlier today is
there are some which have two or three
disjointed built-up areas and that's for
a variety of reasons okay technically
they could well be that there is no
continuous part
the village and each individual one is
either continuous I'm looking at Loxley
and then I look at Long Marston for
which council the bronze has an interest
and suddenly find that the built-up area
boundaries in two parts
but that is deliberate greater Owen is
in three okay for any Compton's in two
but the extra bit there is be covering
because they've got very old fashioned
Victorian concept of a railway station
considerably distant from the parish or
the settlement and in fact there is
development around it and the idea yes
of built-up area boundaries is to
constrain a development in open
countryside and the core strategy has a
number of policies to do that and
establishing the built-up area
boundaries will enable us to have far
better control over that particular
situation and remove all question of
doubts about where the boundary should
or shouldn't be which is inevitably the
situation you end up in in the short
term so basically I bring to you
but the built-up area boundaries still
to go in the site allocations plan which
isn't yet complete and is likely we
think to be ready for approval perhaps
in January based on a meeting we had
last week but effectively this is fixed
and final and cabinet approval will give
some guidance to the development
management teams over what is and isn't
going to be in the final policy
documentation counsel Rich's Thank You
chair and so some of the residents in my
ward had some confusion over the over
the be UAB fees of a neighborhood
planning and it might be worth at this
point clarifying the position which I
know that we've done previously outside
of this meets in the world John is in
the room in so much that my
understanding of the bu abies is that
they don't Trump the neighborhood
planning process no and therefore if
parishes and communities are identifying
small chunks of development land
themselves through the neighborhood plan
that isn't overridden by the be UAB so
that that's as I understand it which I
believe to be true John's nodding but I
think it's wise for us to clarify that
in public
well I'm happy for John to make a
comment my take on that is that when the
officers did their work on producing
this report and producing the boundaries
they took account of parcels of land
that were in own an emerging
neighborhood plans and made certain they
were inside the built-up area boundary
could you come forward John to a
microphone just a comment on this place
yes Thank You chair I can confirm that
the these Jaffe's built up a rebound
just won't Trump neighbor plans the
purpose of drawing them now was to give
some certainty so the development
management process and/or see your
members will see in the covering report
there's a list of settlements where the
built up area boundaries have not been
redrawn because they've always already
been drawn through the MDP process and
we fully appreciate that as more maple
parents come forward they will then take
the lead in determining what the
appropriate boundary is for those areas
and they may include sites that
currently undeveloped and the boundaries
and the site locations plan will be
amended to reflect any changes okay I
don't see any other hand up
apart from council organ fiddling with
her hair but I don't think she's bidding
to speak right so the recommendations on
page 17 the built up area boundaries set
out in Appendix 1 are received and
endorsed as appropriate to be included
within the emerging draft site
allocations plan so agreed thank you
right item 7 safeguarding policy so I'm
hesitating because I'm looking to save
neck ads in the room and ease and so
hopefully mister wheeze can do it with
any any queries that we might have on
this it's use it oh dear so how do I get
out of that little holloway name right
the safeguarding policy for adults is a
policy you'll see it's attached to the
pen ds1 and we are asked to adopt this I
understand from the monitoring officer
this is a policy area that council
cabinet can adopt he's thinking now just
to be clear the law sets out a number of
policies that the council as a body must
adopt it then sets out other policies
which by by convention or otherwise
council should adopt and because this
subject has such wide ramifications for
staff counselors and the general public
my advice was that it should be signed
off by full council right so that's why
it says recommended to council right and
okay well apologies for misleading you
there I didn't intend to do so we'll
have to repeat this then when we come to
the matter
however what I have to say about this
policy is but it's one of those which is
countywide in its conception and
creation and you'll see if you look at
appendix one on page 69 but it's got the
logos of all the five districts in
Warwickshire we do have to work with
Warwickshire police and we also have to
work with warrior County Council Adult
Services Department in the
implementation right so consequently you
have the documents for reportage and the
documents for those issues which we
might be dealing with
but do have to be passed on to the
worries of safeguarding adults board we
also have a statement to help guide our
officers called the vulnerable adults
statement which is appendix 2 on page
100 and annoying and that lists
that's a strap of district council
statement but that lists and I suspect
the creation of this has been shared
with the other bodies mr. Webb will no
doubt sort of clarify that point with me
but effectively the questions that are
in the vulnerable adults a statement or
the statements or the details that are
in there do highlight some of the more
difficult issues for example if someone
is suffering from some mental health
problem you read unfortunately in the
news of rather awkward situations where
even the carers looking after them can
get a little violent fortunately those
situations are few and far between but
that would not that behavior would not
be tolerated under the Warwickshire wide
statement that we're being asked to
endorse so basically mr. Webb will
answer any detailed questions that
members have and then we'll put it to
the vote
yes mr. Webber just to just to reinforce
the importance of signing up to this
safeguarding is one of the biggest
issues the council's face whether it's
for children or adults and it is vitally
important that officers and members play
a part in safeguarding role hence that
in terms of this
the lead member for safeguarding is
yourself the leader and I'm the lead
officer for safeguarding so that gives a
demonstration of some of the importance
that the statement shows us as a council
in terms of our intents and signing up
to the safeguarding protocols and only
today the County Council who occur with
an eye to the safeguarding have will be
issuing some information there was
something in each of the members
pigeonholes this week around
safeguarding giving an update in terms
of where we are on safeguarding and just
to finish off safeguarding is considered
significant importance the council in as
much as everybody has to go on training
on safeguarding training gets Monday to
read that everybody goes on training so
it's just really to put that into some
context about the importance of signing
up to this okay and indeed there's been
member training and I know I've been on
the safeguarding member training as
organized by mr. Chapman it's these
people CAD in chat but that's confused
me you see they work there their day job
is with mr. weeks you see so that's why
I got confused about who does what and
indeed those courses will no doubt be
repeated from time to time because it's
certainly important I think for members
to appreciate where we are especially
now that local authorities at this level
I've got to take a direct interest in
solutions and indeed the management of
vulnerable adults okay I don't see any
other hands up so I'm going to the
recommendation to Council from page 65
and that's basically these that we adopt
the safeguarding policy in Appendix 1
but I guess that the other statements
that attach to it and go with it so the
whole package will get referred so great
thank you
item 8 treasury management strategy
mid-year review counselor organ Thank
You chairman this item is the midterm
report of the council's treasury
management strategy which was approved
in February this year and updates the
position in the light of the prevailing
economic conditions the council
employees capita Asset Services who
advise on treasury management and
investment matters an economic update is
provided in paragraph 2 of the report
along with an interest rate forecast I
think there has to be a bit of a wealth
warning on that as it does vary from
time to time the cancer's priority is to
ensure security of capital and liquidity
and to obtain an appropriate level of
return that is consistent with the
council's risk appetite the continuing
potential for the reemergence of a
eurozone sovereign debt crisis together
with other risks which could impact on
the credit worthiness of thanks from a
low risk strategy given this risk
environment investment returns are
likely to remain low the approved limits
within the annual investment strategy
have not been breached during the first
six months and the investment
counterparty criteria selection approved
by the treasury management strategy is
meeting the requirement of the treasury
management function the cats apparently
has no external borrowing or debt nor is
there an expectation that Boeing will be
undertaken during this financial year
and the recommendation to Council is to
note the report including the Treasury
activity detailed in Paris five one two
five four thank you
councillor Jefferson I would fully
endorse Elwood councillor organ said
about the need for a health warning on
some of the economic forecasts in the
paper fairly blunt statement what
confuses me is how the media at large
right seemed to want answers on briggsie
which they know bloody well are more
lines that could reveal themselves in
about 18 months time so I'm referring to
national journalists now right just give
Ben an indication I'm not having a snipe
at him but it does seem to be remarkable
that you know there seems to be all this
high expectation with everybody involved
should know every answer to implement
tomorrow and we know that's not going to
happen so I can see obviously the need
to take economic forecast with a pinch
of salt because the questions over
brexit will appear when the negotiations
are finished if indeed the negotiations
do finish but I'm sure there'll be a
solution and there'll be an exit somehow
councillor Jefferson I think chaired I
do agree with what you say about
briggsie taking people's on the off the
ball there's little doubt that the
performance of the UK economy since
roughly 2010 has been absolutely abysmal
particularly as regards productivity
that's going to hit real incomes and
it's also going to hit the amount of
revenue the government gets so we are
entering a fairly risky time so I
thought that you can't have performance
of the UK was quite good not abysmal now
it's abysmal chair
sorry what do you need it a bit better
you need to make a bobble till on money
in your line of business here obviously
I have a I should make a declaration
that I'm involved in investment business
but I would suggest that the UK growth
is better than we're guessing here with
appropriate risk management I think we
could do better but then I just have to
imagine in line with the council's rest
recipe okay nothing more to say them
okay so consequently if there's no more
contributions the recommendation again
to Council is to note the report
including the Treasury activity the sort
of things that mr. Buckland has been
getting his his fingers soiled on right
is that agreed right item nine the
counts of fraud and bribery corruption
framework I have to report that I've
allowed to this item to come forward to
cabinet today but on the basis of a
recommendation from the portfolio holder
councillor organ and not on the basis of
a recommendation from the audit and
standards committee it is right that the
audit and Standards Committee could be
consulted and their view is that of a
console t but I've without going on
about it I've had discussions with
various officers including mr. Buckland
who did concede that the matter should
have been handled in the way I've just
described so I hope that when the issue
is minuted today it will be on the basis
of a proposal from the portfolio holder
in consultation with the
didn't Standards Committee dancer organ
Thank You chairman cabinet approved the
current counter fraud and bribery policy
in April 2014 and proposed changes to
the policy detailed the council's
commitment to reducing the risk of fraud
also to incorporate corruption within
the policy the significant significant
additions and amendments are detailed in
the report and these changes have been
consulted on by audit and standards
committee recommendation is to approve
the updated counter fraud bribery and
corruption policy thank you any comments
No
so right so the original summary says to
consider the recommendation without a
record resolution that was wrong so
consequently we've got to make up a
recommendation and the recommendation is
that we update the counter for bribery
and corruption policy no that's the
recommendation counts the thermal from
the audience Standards Committee have
you not heard what I have said right
thank you we're not working on that
we're working on a proposal from the
portfolio although right does that agree
right that um right the other items ten
items 10 11 and 12 are on block items
I've had no requests to actually
withdraw those so constant get so to
pull those out so do you agree those on
unblock that we note the cabinet receive
it right item 13 urgent business no
urgent business chairman right that
concludes the business of the meeting
cabinet meeting this afternoon some of
us have another meeting shortly did we
want to bring that forward
well I thought you were involved in this
extra meeting that we've done here I
have got well the kavanah meeting is
closed